bonjour michel fayyad
bonjour merci d'être avec nous on dirait
ce matin sur rtl france la collusion
entre la justice et la politique au
liban c'est un problème récurrent
oui le pouvoir judiciaire n'est pas
séparée du pouvoir politique cela fait
des années que ces réclames et par un
certain nombre de libanais aujourd'hui
il ya un projet de loi qui pour séparer
le pouvoir politique du pouvoir
judiciaire qui traînent dans les allées
au parlement depuis des années est un
peu ce projet d'indépendance de la
justice n'est même pas soumis à ce qu'on
appelle la commission de venise qui est
une commission internationale européenne
et internationale
chargée en fait de voir si les projets
d'indépendance de justice sont
réellement valable qui peuvent vraiment
séparer la politique qui de la justice
donc on en est malheureusement encore
loin malgré fait que ce soit une révolte
revendications très important de la
plupart des libanais non justement lundi
à new york le conseil de sécurité de
l'onu a de nouveau souligné la nécessité
d'une enquête rapide indépendante et
impartiale
la france elle aussi a appelé hier la
justice libanaise à travailler en toute
transparence finalement la communauté
internationale qu'elle a réellement les
moyens de faire pression sur les
autorités libanaises en matière de
justice
en fait on l'a vu par exemple au moment
de la formation du gouvernement la
communauté internationale a mis la
pression sur la classe politique
libanaise et il a fallu quand même de
nombreux mois avant qu'il y ait un
gouvernement
donc la classe politique pense que le
temps le temps est avec m c'est ça c'est
ça en fait le problème
ce qui veut dire que le juge bitar qui
est en charge de l'enquêté
il est en ce moment les eaux au coeur
d'une campagne de dénigrement il risque
aussi d'être écartée du dossier comme
son prédécesseur on février dernier vous
lis tout à fait il risque cela est
probablement ce ce qui va arriver en
fait ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que les
banques la cour de cassation qui
écartait le juge peter et son
prédécesseur a également et qu' il ya
quelques jours le 15 septembre à donner
l'immunité au gouverneur de la banque
centrale riad salamé et est donc en fait
c'est cour de cassation est complètement
politiser le procureur général près la
cour de cassation est ouvertement
en fait partisan du courant du futur de
saad hariri mais mais les interférences
ne se limite pas à ça va gérer puisque
on l'a vu justement l'ancien ministre
nouvelle machine qui annonce ministre de
s'avérer mais est soutenu par l'ensemble
du leadership sunnite mais également par
les partis chiites comme amal et le
hezbollah donc on voit bien que cette
coalition en fait de plusieurs partis
politiques en faveur des interférences
dans la justice pour ne pas être jugé
parce que les principaux en fait si vous
voulez accusé par le juge bitar sont
soit des membres des partis uniques soit
des partis chiites soi même des parties
de ruz il y en a également à un chrétien
qui est membre du d'un parti minoritaire
bellemare d'heure mais en fait tous ces
partis en fait sombre sont comme une
coalition au liban ils ont les miellés
des idées qui sont assez proches au
niveau du blocage des réformes
financières et bancaires et on voit le
blocage qui a eu en entreprenant de
longs mois avec le dans les négociations
avec le fmi en raison de leurs intérêts
de leurs interférences et maintenant on
voit aussi les blocages au niveau
judiciaire également en raison de ces
mêmes partis alors les libanais on l'a
vu un manifestent leur colère par
rapport à cette enquête bloqué sur le
port de beyrouth mais finalement la
colère va beaucoup plus loin puisque
c'est tout un système qui est mis en
cause depuis des mois et pour l'instant
rien avant sur ce dossier malgré les
quelques injonctions de la france
oui comme je disais en fait cette classe
politique n'a en fait ne considère pas
qu'elle est vraiment sur ou sous
pression ils voient que leur pouvoir
continue et ils sont vu aussi que la
communauté internationale
en fait leurs amis grande pression mais
finalement à accepter un premier
ministre de laurent parce qu'il faut
savoir quand même que nagib mikati qui
était enfin été promu ministre deux fois
auparavant c'est un banquier
et c'est le plus l'homme le plus riche
du liban et c'est en fait finalement la
communauté nationale a accepté que qu'il
y ait un des membres de cette même
classe qui arrivent au pouvoir une quand
on disait on veut un gouvernement de
personnes indépendantes de personnes de
technocrates etc mais ça commence par le
poste de premier ministre si on met au
poste de premier ministre un quelqu'un
d'un politicien et en plus quelqu'un qui
a participé au blocage du plan qui avait
été accepté par le fmi on peut pas
espérer réellement des réformes on peut
pas vraiment espérer un changement
maintenant ils ont ils ont même envisagé
de
d'interdire le voit des libanais de
l'étranger et ils ont également vous le
jouez sur
en fait l'organisation des élections et
souhaiterait les organiser à l'avance et
ça c'est pour laisser encore moins de
temps à en fait au nouveau au nouveau
parti au nouveau mouvement de
s'organiser et également pour mettre la
pression contre le président de la
république michel merci beaucoup michel
fayyad pour votre travail ce matin dans
la matinale des francs je rappelle vous
êtes analyste politique et financier